Bitte schön.
Hallo. Mein Name ist Bülger Oglu.
Ich bin auf dieser Statue als Assistenz Arztetich.
Ich bin für diejenigen, die das Aufnahme gespielt haben.
Herr Doktor, sagen Sie mir nochmal,
Ihren richtigen Familiennamen.
Mein Name ist Bülger Oglu.
Bülger Oglu.
Ja, ja, das ist richtig.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich möchte Ihre Beschwerde erzählen.
Ich möchte ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, was Sie wissen müssen, müssen Sie natürlich fragen.
Ja.
Danke. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Joachim Schäfer.
Achim Schäfer.
Joachim Schäfer.
Ich bin ein Mann.
Okay. Joachim Schäfer.
Herr Schäfer. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 17.04.75.
75. Okay, danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 m.
80? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
90 kg.
Okay, danke für die Informationen.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, das ist jetzt erst ganz vor kurzer Zeit aufgetreten.
Ich habe seit 2 Stunden ganz heftige Schmerzen.
Hier im rechten Rückenbereich.
Das strahlt also heftig aus.
Das sind ganz, ganz starke Schmerzen.
Was mir schon aufgefallen ist,
dass ich ganz oft auf die Toilette gehen muss,
das habe ich jetzt die Tage schon gemerkt.
Und dass das auch ein bisschen wehtut beim Wasserlassen.
Sie haben gesagt, seit 2 Stunden
in der rechten Rückenbereich haben Sie heftige Schmerzen.
Ja, es sind richtig ganz schlimme Schmerzen.
Sie gehen in die Toilette so viel.
Ja, genau.
Ich muss ganz oft und dann kommt nur ganz wenig.
Okay, ganz oft.
Ganz wenig.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie noch etwas Beschwerden?
Das war alles.
Das langt mir völlig.
Ich habe solche heftigen Schmerzen.
Ich kann mich ja kaum rühren.
Ich musste mich auch einmal schon übergeben.
Übergeben, einmal übergeben.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht erlauben,
dass ich bei meiner Arbeit gebraucht bin.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich kann mir das nicht erlauben, krank zu sein.
Ich brauche schnelle Hilfe jetzt.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Schäfer, strahlende Schmerzen?
Ja, das strahlt in die Leiste rein.
Und das strahlt bis ins Genital rein.
Sehr heftig.
Genital.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala einordnen?
Wobei ein leichter Schmerz ist ein unerträglicher Schmerz.
Das ist ein leichter Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen, das ist bei acht bestimmt.
Okay.
Können Sie am Ende des Geschenkpräts diese Schmerzen aushalten
oder soll ich mir gleich ein Schmerzmittel geben?
Es wird ja nicht so lange dauern.
Warten Sie bitte noch einen Moment.
Okay, fünf, zehn Minuten.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt schon eine Weile.
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Nachdem ich mich übergeben habe, ist es ein bisschen besser,
aber ich fühle mich schon nicht gut.
Okay, nicht Übelkeit jetzt.
Nein, jetzt im Augenblick nicht.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie diese Beschiwerte in Vergangenheit erlebt
oder das ist das erste Mal?
So etwas habe ich überhaupt noch nicht erlegt.
Ich habe auch solche heftigen Schmerzen.
Also wie gesagt, dass ich jetzt zu oft zur Toilette muss,
das ist schon einige Tage.
Aber jetzt diese Schmerzen,
nee, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay, danke.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich meine, also ich wieg mich nicht so oft,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass mein Gewicht sich verändert hat.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme, Herr Schäfer?
Ich meine, du Schlafstörung, ein Schlafstörung?
Nein, letzte Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen,
weil ich immer auf die Toilette musste,
aber normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Wobei ich berufsbeding immer sehr früh aufdehne muss,
dadurch muss ich auch immer früh schlafen gehen.
Okay, und?
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise gar nicht, nein, jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, ich habe Probleme.
Du hast Probleme?
Ja, ja, da umso mehr jetzt im Auge.
Normalerweise auch nicht.
Haben Sie Ihre Urin Blut bemerkt?
Ja, sagen Sie etwas, ja, das stimmt.
Da war so ein bisschen roter Spuren drin, das habe ich gesehen, ja.
Okay.
Gut, gesehen.
Und das war, diese Urin war klar oder korrupt?
Ja, so genau sieht man das ja nicht,
wenn das dann im Becken ist, mischt sich das ja mit Wasser,
aber ich würde sagen, das war durchsichtig, ja, also klar.
Klar, okay.
Danke.
Herr Schäfer, ich möchte über Ihre kranken Geschichte fragen.
Gibt es Ihnen Ihre vorgeschichte Krankheiten von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also, das...
Entschuldigen.
Bitte schön.
Okay, wir machen weiter, ja.
Herr Schäfer, gibt es Ihnen Ihre vorgeschichte Krankheiten von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Das weiß ich, ja, das hat man vor vier Jahren mal festgestellt.
Und alles andere, naja, das sind so Sachen, die halt auch mit der Arbeit zu tun haben.
Ich habe immer wieder so Sehenscheidenentzündung am Arm.
Da muss ich eigentlich auch so eine Ortese tragen, so eine Bandage.
Aber das kann ich bei der Arbeit halt eigentlich nicht.
Und ja, kürzlich, also gestern ist das passiert,
habe ich mir auch eine Verbrennung an dem anderen Arm zugezogen.
Das passiert häufiger mal, wissen Sie, ich bin Bäcker von Beruf
und arbeite in der Backstube, bin selbstständig.
Und ja, da kommt man schon mal irgendwo gegen den Ofen oder gegen ein heißes Blech
und dann verbrennt man sich halt ein bisschen.
Das ist aber Berufskrankheit bei uns, ja.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben erhöhte Blutdruck seit vier Jahren.
Genau.
Seit vier Jahren. Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, das heißt, ich glaube, ich dildteer 10 das Zeug.
Dildteer 10, dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Okay. Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine, da steht 90 drauf.
90, okay.
Danke. Haben Sie noch etwas, zum Beispiel,
Südddruck über Funktionen und Telefonktionen,
Blutdruckerkrankheit, erhöhte Blutdrucker?
Nein, so etwas habe ich alles nicht.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und Sie haben gesagt, ich habe Orteese gehabt, ja?
Ja, die soll ich eigentlich tragen,
weil ich mir immer an den Unterarm diese Sehnenscheidenentzündung habe.
Aber das kann ich bei der Arbeit natürlich nicht tragen.
Okay, okay.
Wann war das,
die Orteese, welche Art empfiehlt und wann war das?
Also die soll ich halt tragen wegen der Unterarme.
Und das kommt immer wieder.
Und zum letzten Mal war das jetzt akut vor einem Monat.
Und ich kann die aber eigentlich eben bei der Arbeit,
ich kann die wohl tragen, wenn ich im Haus irgendwas mache zu Hause.
Aber so bei der Arbeit.
Okay, danke.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Schäfer?
Nein, ich habe noch nie eine Operation gehabt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Und haben Sie Allergie, Herr Schäfer?
Ja, ich habe sogar eine ganz dofe Allergie,
auch beruflich sehr schlecht,
und nämlich eine Gegenwestenstiche.
Welche Allergie konnte ich nicht akustisch verstanden?
Gegen Westpinstiche.
Westpinstiche.
Und wo Kuchen ist, im Sommer westen ja nicht weit.
Und insofern muss ich da immer sehr aufpassen,
dass ich da nicht gestochen werde.
Okay, wie urstest ist diese Allergie?
Ja, da kriege ich ganz dramatisch,
also dass ich keine Luft mehr bekomme
und dass die Schleimhäute anschwellen.
Also das sollte ich schon möglichst vermeiden.
Schleimhäute, Schwellung, ja?
Okay.
Haben Sie Unfertigkeit?
Ja, das ist noch nicht so ganz raus,
aber es scheint so zu sein, dass ich Laktose nicht vertrage.
Ich habe das gemerkt,
dass ich auf Milch so ein bisschen reagiere mit Bauchbeschwerden,
aber zurzeit trinke ich praktisch keine Milch.
Und wenn Sie Milch trinken, haben Sie Beleihungung, ja?
Ja, Bauchbeschwerden, und mal Durchfall und mal Beleihung gelaufen.
Okay.
Und Herr Schäfer, ich möchte über Ihre Eltern fragen.
Lieben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben beide noch.
Das ist gut, Gott sei Dank.
Könnten Sie bitte über Ihre Eltern vor Erkrankungen erwähnen?
Ja, so genau weiß ich das nicht, was Sie haben.
Also ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater etwas hat.
Er hat eine Verschlusskrankheit an dem rechten Bein
und hat eine offene Stelle.
Und dem ist vor einem Jahr so etwas,
ist die rechte Großzehe abgenommen worden,
weil er dadurch Blutwungstörungen hatte.
Okay.
Großzehe?
Die rechte Großzehe, ja.
Abgenommen.
Okay, verstehe.
Könnten Sie bitte über Ihre Mutter erwähnen?
Eigentlich ist die Gesundheit so ein bisschen Probleme
mit der Wirbelsäule.
Aber die läuft so ein bisschen krumm,
aber die ist auch nicht mehr jung.
Also ja, aber eigentlich ist die sonst fit ziemlich.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe Geschwister, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Schäfer, sind Sie verratet?
Ich lebe zurzeit getrennt von meiner Frau.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, die sind aber bei meiner Frau.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja, ja.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sie haben gesagt, ich bin Bäcker?
Ja, genau, ich habe eine eigene Bäckerei.
Okay, sind Sie zufrieden mit Ihrer Arbeit?
Ja.
Was weiß ich, da wächst man ja so rein.
Also wenn man eigene Firmen hat,
dann ist man ja selber derjenige, der entscheidet.
Und doch eigentlich bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Es ist natürlich viel Arbeit, ja, das ist schon klar.
Und es ist überhaupt nichts sehr schwer, Personal zu bekommen.
Herr Schäfer, ich möchte über Ihre Alkoholkonsum und Zigaretten fragen.
Rauchen Sie?
Seit fünf Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich bin sehr stolz drauf, dass Sie sich das aufgegeben haben.
Okay.
Aufgehört, okay.
Wie lange waren Sie Raucher?
Ich bin über 20 Jahre alt.
Ja, über 20 Jahre.
Wie viel Zigaretten hatten Sie pro Tag geraucht?
Ja, wenn schon denn schon.
Also ein Päckchen am Tag war das sicher.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol.
Nach Feierabend zum Einschlafen trinke ich 2-3 Gläser Bier abends.
Also Schnaps oder so, trinke ich nicht.
Okay, 2-3 Gläser Bier, ja? Feiertage, Feiertage.
Ne, abends so, am Feierabend.
Feierabend, okay.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Seit ich aus der Schule bin, als junger Mann trinkte man natürlich auch mit seinen Kumpels.
Wollte man sagen 30 Jahre?
Gut und gerne ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich Herr Schäfer, das ist eine roten Frage.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nie was zu tun gehabt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Freiben Sie Sport Herr Schäfer?
Ja, ich würde es nicht sagen.
Manchmal, wenn ich am Wochenende frei habe, fahre ich ein bisschen Fahrrad.
Oder, was weiß ich, wenn es sehr warm ist, wie ich auch mal schwimmen.
Aber meistens komme ich nicht so richtig dazu.
Okay, sind Sie schon gegen Corona geivt?
Ja klar, gegen Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Dreimal geimpft, okay.
Und haben Sie in der sechs Monate Auslandreisen unternommen?
Nein, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Herr Schäfer, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie an mich?
Ja, langsam wird es unangenehm mit den Schmerzen.
Es wäre schon gut, wenn ich ein Medikament bekommen könnte.
Oder auch, wenn Sie mir sagen, was man dagegen tun kann.
Okay.
Woher kommt diese Schmerzen?
Ich würde vorschlagen, dass wir folgendermaßen vorgehen.
Ich würde Ihnen körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann würde ich Ihnen etwas Blut abnehmen.
Danach würde ich Bildgebende untersuchen.
Was wäre eine Bildgebende Untersuchung?
Das ist zwei Ebene.
Z.B. eine Bauchgrafie.
Eine Bauchgrafie?
Röntgenaufnahme.
Zwei Ebene, Röntgenaufnahme.
Eine Röntgenaufnahme, okay.
Dann würde ich Ultraschall beantragen.
Okay. Was kann man da sehen?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, dass das Könntes bei uns vorliegt.
Können wir schiebleschen?
Ja.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Ich verlasse mich auf Sie, dass Sie das machen, was möglich ist.
Wo muss ich jetzt hingehen?
Wo muss ich hingehen?
Ich muss im Wartestimmer warten.
Nehmen Sie bitte im Wartestimmer Platz.
Ich rufe gleich Sie auf.
Sehr gut.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ja, fühlen Sie sich feblich?
Oder haben Sie viel?
Ah!
Sagt er nichts dazu.
Ich glaube, er fühlt sich eher nicht feblich.
Er hat nicht gemessen.
Und kein Schüttelfrost?
Nein, Schüttelfrost hat er auch nicht.
Danke schön.
Ja.
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage.
Für mich ist Ihren Name etwas schwierig.
Deswegen würde ich gerne bitten, ein Buch zu bieren.
Vorname j o a c h i m yu achim
und Schäfer, wie der Mann, der die Schafe hütet.
Also s c h a umlaut f e r.
Okay, danke.
Hatten Sie einen Umfall?
Ein Umfall?
Ja, nur diesen kleinen Unfall.
Da mit meinem Backblech, wo ich mir den Arm verbrannt habe.
Sonst hatte ich keinen Umfall.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie ja dumpfstechend, brennend,
kolikartig?
Ja, also, die sind krampfartig, kolikartig sind die.
Und ich denke, Sie sind sehr kundlich.
Und ich denke, Sie sind ja rückensstechend.
Rückensstechend.
Sind die Schmerzen einen Wellenfirmig verlaufen,
das heißt, Sie wellen sie immer wieder an und ab.
Ja, krampfartig, ja, krampfartig sind die.
Wellenfirmig.
Okay.
Es gibt bestimmt auch Schmerzen.
Ich habe die erst zwei Stunden, ja, also ich weiß keinen Auslöser
und ich habe bisher auch nichts gefunden, was dagegen hilft.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, oder ich verstehe richtig,
oder nicht, welche Medikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Gegen die Schmerzen habe ich noch gar nichts eingenommen.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, hat er gefragt, habe ich verneint.
Drogenkonsum, nicht gefragt.
Hat er auch gefragt, habe ich auch verneint.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Sind die Schmerzen eher die Fuß,
oder können Sie die lokalisieren?
Ich kann die schon lokalisieren, die sind im rechten Rücken.
Im rechten Rückenbereich.
Und sie strahlen in die Leiste aus und ins Genital.
Genital.
Du hast dich angefangen, mit der Zeit verschwinden?
Ja.
Du hast dich plötzlich angefangen.
Ja, plötzlich angefangen.
Aber mit der Zeit...
Ich weiß, plötzlich angefangen,
aber mit der Zeit, die die Schmerzen sind,
verschleht, oder?
Ja, ich habe dir jetzt zwei Stunden, ich habe diese Schmerzen zwei Stunden
und sie sind seit zwei Stunden krass, also höftig.
Okay.
Sie haben gegeben eine Schmerzintensität von acht.
Ja, sehr häufig.
Also, der ist wie erschlagen von seinen Schmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt, ihre Arm, Finger, eine Probleme,
könnten Sie bitte genau beschreiben, ich verstehe nicht...
Er hat zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Er hat durch die Arbeitsbelastung,
hat er eine Sehnen-Entzündung im Unterarm
und muss eigentlich eine Ortese tragen.
Das kann er aber bei seiner Arbeit als Bäcker nicht.
Ja, weil aus hygienischen Gründen.
Er kann diese Ortese nicht tragen,
weil er dann seine Hände nicht waschen kann.
Ja, gut.
Also trägt er die nicht.
Dann hat er ein anderes Problem,
dass er sich kürzlich verbrannt hat,
an einem Backblech.
Er hat sich eine Brandwunde zugezogen,
am linken Arm, aber er sagt, das habe ich ständig.
Was man sich vorstellen kann,
wenn man in einer Bäckerei arbeitet,
immer mit großen schweren heißen Sachen umgeht,
dass man sich da leicht mal verbrennt.
Ja, also zwei verschiedene Verletzungen an den Armen,
die aber nichts mit dem Bauchschmerzen
oder mit den Rhythmischmerzen zu tun haben.
Dankeschön.
Ja.
Können wir erst mal zuerst mal anfangen?
Hatten Sie früher einen hier Beschiwärten gehabt?
Nein, das habe ich auch, hat er gefragt,
habe ich auch gesagt, ne, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Das Einzige, was ich gesagt habe,
seit einigen Tagen habe ich das gemerkt,
dass das Wasser lassen weh tut
und dass ich eben häufiger gehen muss.
Aber solche Schmerzen hatte ich noch nie.
Okay?
Ich habe oft Wasser lassen
und die Nücher, die gestern die Nücher
und die Sonne, einige Tage, was bedeutet,
ein Tage oder ein, zwei Tage?
Zwei Tage, zwei, drei Tage.
Das hat sich langsam verschlechtert, ja.
Haben wir über Fieber gesprochen?
Nein.
Hat gerade jemand gefragt,
ich habe keine Angaben zu Fieber.
Also ich denke mal, er hat sich nicht gemessen
und er fühlt sich aber auch nicht fieberig.
Okay, danke.
Jochen.
Okay.
Schmerzen.
Schmerzen und diese heftigen Schmerzen.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Guten Tag Frau Obererstin. Ich habe neue Patienten aufgenommen. Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich, um Ihnen vorzustellen?
Natürlich. Wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay, ja. Unsere Patient heißt Herrn Joachim Schäfer. Er sei 48 Jahre alt und 1,83 Meter groß und 90 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns aufgrund bestehender progretierender...
... bestehender...
... mit Ausschütterung in den genitalen Bereich FOA.
Der Patient, diese Schimmersen, die Schimmersen, sind prampfartig und drückende Schmerzstöcher.
Die Schimmersen sind einmal übergeben.
Die Schimmersen sind auf der Schmerzskala 8.
Der Patient hat im Wasserlassen Blut bemerkt im Urin.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Insomni und Dizuri.
Die Frage nach Gewichtsveränderungen, Defekationprobleme und Stölferost, wie Fieber, wurden verneint.
Er habe links arm verbrannt.
Vor einem Monat hat ein Arzt den Patienten die Ortese empfangen.
Er konnte ihn nicht tragen, weil er sie nicht tragt.
Warum hat er die Ortese verordnet bekommen?
Er hat den Patienten die Ortese empfangen.
Er hat allergisch gegen Westpinstiche.
Er hat die Ortese empfangen.
Er hat einen großen Sieg abgenommen.
Er hat eine große Wunder.
Er hat eine Pläfur K, mit Ulkofkurs und mit Zustand nach Großdekorps.
Er hat die Mutti des Patienten leider unter Wertebrat Probleme.
Er erinnert sich nicht auf die Diagnose.
Er ist mit seiner Frau getrennt.
Er hat drei Kinder. Er ist Beka.
Er hat drei Glaspia.
Er schreibt Sport.
Er hat drei Mal gegen Corona geimpft.
Was machen Sie für operative Untersuchungen?
Was werden Sie da sehen?
Was sehen Sie?
Was wäre die nächste Option?
Was machen Sie für operative Untersuchungen?
Was wäre die Therapie für diesen Patienten?
Was wäre die nächste Option?
Was gehen wir an den Stein ran?
Stoß?
Stoß.